so we've got the rematch coming mmm
playing him something different for a
change unlocking defense probably
butchering the pronunciation again okay
he obviously has some sort of idea but
quick a form i really have helped how is
this play too maybe I should I don't
know g6 like a nuts let's play g6 I
actually agree Kyrie captured with the
sea porn and in the rare case is where i
played this opening i played it takes t6
rock III Wow
yeah this is a very very creative way of
playing but I'm not sure I shouldn't you
develop some minor pieces also it's not
doing so much on g3 this rock so Bishop
f5 actually wins the tempo down right
before yeah okay let's let's go for that
like a basset c250 to square me ok let's
open the center with the rukon g3 yeah I
can play d5 of course is also possible
night before now I am before
Oh interesting my idea is actually night
d 75 using using both nights on the
queenside bishop d2s maybe in an issue i
have 85 yeah very weird position [ __ ]
with this funny rook placement queen to
d7 is it possible to play go into this
Helen okay let's not spend too much time
night a for the funny funny point
attacking be too and i'm not sure how he
reacts now to that c4 so you fall before
94 but i can go here of course this was
was an idea all along now intending 93
no this really a strange game let's just
cancel and maybe continue with you form
yeah I had was to Sir castling was
really too slow add this was bad it was
really bad now he is able to castle and
this is really not what I wanted
all right I shouldn't I must play a form
before that of course before I castle so
that I can actually give this check on
d3 now we can castle and it's only it's
not even comparable and strength
of course it is playable it's not like
I'm in terrible shape but the other was
something much stronger I take the 60
yeah I'm down on down on the clock be to
hang g3 hanging so just capture or is
the same thing return maybe I can I can
do this
now I'm looking for he can maybe just
play looking for ok here I thought I
could play with her five coming I mean
we won no no Bishop Bishop fan but those
nights are really nice
yeah at least year we'll need something
was a nice trick but I didn't didn't see
that
yeah that's that should be winning yeah
the night son we're really menacing on
d3 enter before there's some quicker way
to to do that it's only not now then
it's even slightly problematic because
of the time situation
34 seconds okay want to go King to d7
and then invade with the rook the King
needs to protect the weakness on d6 and
Denmark enters its not not I can all he
can have the two parts the ks is
blocking them both not winning the
bishop why it was it was my first
thought it would be a bit tricky
technically but it wasn't the King just
cooperates nicely yeah I really played
this castle some castles with bed i mean
i really think i played this quite
nicely t i really need to do something
out i mean just just here and now i am
able to to play to d3 with with him can
them catching the king in the center and
here he is somehow wriggled out of this
I mean it still looks nice but it's not
a big edge or something yeah here there
are alternatives I can take on c1 this
is actually good with Queen F for coming
yeah ok but I needed to fly quickly he
needs to play rookie for this is really
unclear and this now is it's working
very nicely in my favor yeah until I
black wins yeah thanks for watching